salut je suis un lille j'ai le droit de
dire où tu habites à lille oui je suis
ok avec cyril alias super première de la
chaîne super connard monsieur cyrille a
chanté qui guida la gentillesse de
m'offrir un fish and chips pour ma patte
et jusqu'ici fish and chips du nord
totalement atypique dont vous avez pu
voir dans le titre je vais essayer de
faire un truc de mentalisme sur série il
ne m'a pas menacé il ne m'a pas payé et
n'a pas demandé ça veut dire ça j'ai une
vraie question posée ciel alors n'y
répond pas mais si tu devais très
incarnée et que dieu te disais la
réincarnation pour toi sera forcément
dans un jeu vidéo
tu pourrais être n'importe quels objets
ou personnages ce que tu veux dans un
jeu vidéo et je vais te demander de
réfléchir à quoi ça pourrait faire
référence et je vais essayer de trouver
ça tu vois un peu l'idée là tu dois te
demain tu meurs on fait et moi je suis
là c'est pour ça qu'on voit puis dans
les tendances non quelque chose et toi
t'es mort faire dit alors ah mais j'ai
un choix c'est cool indiqué je vais j'ai
peut-être vouloir incarner en en un peu
de fleur dans hitman ou directement on a
un truc particulier préparation mentale
tu vois je fais face à un mur ok donc tu
as ta réincarnation en tête
ouais ok mais je ne sais pas si c'est un
objet un personnage ou autre chose peut
être un objet d'un jeu vidéo ou un objet
qui sert à jouer
vidéo c'est le mec qui commence déjà
donné des contraintes du site us à six
voies non mais c'est ça c'est fade
moi je pense que tu es plus partie sur
un objet mais je la réponse à chaque
fois je suis pas très précis ce qui
permettra un jour
dis-toi que sauf si je te demande de
répondre en disant vasic répond moi ça
sinon on ne répond jamais du coup je
pense que t'as pas choisi un objet sa
cgc a déjà des certitudes berne et
l'effort c'est un peu le fond je te
propose qu'on se retrouvera pour l'autre
vidéo
la prochaine fois pour aller un peu plus
loin mais ça va ça va plus voir un super
et que je le mentalisme comme ça abonnez
vous je me mets derrière vous comme ça
vous pouvez le regarder aussi dans les
yeux donc tu regardes ici l'adjectif tu
penses à la lettre c'est tout à la
première lettre a b c d e f g h i j k l
mn au prs tv w x y z
je pense que j'ai passé la lettre ne
répond pas ça c'est une certitude
c'est de me concentrer c'est pas si
évident que ça alors je suis un cas très
difficile le mental avant tout bâton je
leur faire impôts isi a b c d e actuelle
tout à l'heure j'ai eu une hésitation
sur dès que j'ai plus d e f g h i j k l
mn au pq est restée une vw x y z nancy
je lai je lai et je vais vous expliquer
ce qui se passe en face ici je pense
avoir à la peut donner des choses à nice
on march jeu à temps chez nous tu es sur
cette visée en fait depuis tout à
l'heure je le dis parce que tu vends à
regarder la vidéo
d'habitude je cherche ce qui bouge je
cherche les changements de traction et
toi s'est inversée en fait je trouve que
tu as beaucoup de réactions et que juste
avant une certaine lettre ça bouge - ça
bouge puis ça reprend après mais je
pense que c'est une consonne d'ailleurs
et je vais faire quand même très comme
sa porte
dupuis sans incident est ce que je suis
en train d'écrire parce qu'elle tu peux
nous dire vraiment quelle lettre tu
pensais s'il te plaît m r oui l'appareil
ok donc je sais que c'est pas un objet
que ça commence par la lettre r alors là
me répond qu je pense que c'est un
personnage donc ces quelques couacs être
capté quelque chose qui a incarné dans
le jeu voilà c'est ce que je pense qu'on
ne répond pas ça il ya entre un objet ça
n'allait pas trop fondre choix non plus
mais comme un autre comme ça du coup
maintenant il faut que je cherche le jeu
vidéo en question on se parle r est-ce
que d'après toi je connais ce jeu j'ai
pas une grande culture du jeu vidéo mais
quand même
oui d'accord donc c'est quelque chose de
grand ok ça marche
est ce que tu pourrais imaginer devant
toi comme s'il y avait un écran de
cinéma ton personnage en train d'agir
comme il agit normalement tu vois si
c'est ça commence par air on peut
apprendre maroussi scénario tu
l'imaginés sur une plateforme si c'est
un rider qui imagine en train de grimper
quelque part tu va se lire comme s'il y
avait une séquence à venir et là il ou
elle est en train de faire quelque chose
c'est ça là il faut que j'imagine
d'accord droite gauche c'est un jeu de
plateforme 2d
c'est une affirmation peut-être n'est-ce
pas peut-être peut-être pas on ne sait
pas et tu voudrais vraiment être
réincarné dans ces personnes là dans ce
jeu là d'une vraie volonté de la part
belle à plaisir je dirais plaisir ça te
ferait marrer temps très plaisir ça fait
plaisir
maintenant il faut aussi surveiller
d'histoire trading c'est à dire un petit
tunnel entre avec les informations que
j'ai j'ai un nom du jeu donc place au
napa 200 j'ai aussi mon joe avec un
personnage juste comme ça pour
information ce qui serai sympa qui était
très incarnée dans un bus 37 pouvoir
rouler je vais de temps en temps avec
ses cheveux raides être comme ça à quoi
de faire le pouvoir toi moi qui me
ferait marrer dans ma vie c'est une
manne l2 pour dissocier membres petit
agent d'envoyer mes points après ça un
peu cher mais ça doit bien exister des
jeux comme ça non je pense que je
devrais en manger de boire je te sens
bien saoulé que tu voulais il m'a où il
est bon mais bon c'est long donc ça
c'était le beau jeu c'est rare que tu
pouvais trouver
après si tu aimes le challenge mais peut
aller plus loin d'après vous voit de me
plonger dans la prochaine vidéo et
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas tu vois parce
qu'elle par skype donc encore plus dur
pour moi parce que j'aime autant
d'informations différentes
cela dit moi ça ok mais je me ferai pas
appel
physiquement j'ai fait le genre avec une
cagoule
j'ai fait des erreurs à chaque fois
après visite mr genre tu sais quand tu
disais l'alpha pas cligner des yeux vous
entend et quand j'étais trop concentré
sur la lettre qui arrivent et je me suis
retourné j'ai merdé sait que c'est
maintenant et ici et est normalement de
ses deux petits contrôles et musculaires
ici je rien j'avais très envie de rire
et vous connaissez ou pas super connais
je suis pas sûr que tu peux la
communauté connaissent et utilisent en
fait dites moi un peu est ce qu'il ya
des gamer sur la chaîne parce que moi je
joue beaucoup
j'aime jouer mais j'ai passé temps est
consacré pour reprendre pour jouer comme
j'aime pas deux fois donc je vais jouer
avec la cia et mais je me pose vraiment
la question si j'ai des gamer sur la
chaîne diplôme dans les commentaires si
vous connaissiez cyril avant moi moi je
connais que depuis le mois de janvier
et c'est en moi ta g sur sa table et se
rapproche pour une première fois ça
valait le coup c'est du moins l'avis
d'autres produits exactement c'est que
l'hélicoptère était laissée sur le toit
d'ailleurs régulièrement donné ils
paissent dans lui il fait venir des
hélicos comme ça merci à vous d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo j'espère que ça vous
a plu vous pouvez nous mettre des petits
pouces en l'air
si ça vous a plu je voulais devenir et
valorisant gamin de vol et et c'est
pourquoi leur propose d'utiliser le
monde sait pourquoi
ah non tiens c'est une très bonne
question ça pourquoi tu as chaud là bas
parce que dans les jeux égal et non
parce que tous les personnages ont une
vie de merde
ah ouais genre sa femme et moi c'est la
guerre des alliés mais le marteau avec
un ami il était
j'en avais plein et qui a maintenant
évaluer le cerveau il a perdu sa famille
laiterie l'huile et des prêts si pour
lui la guerre
seul bémol j'ai dit maintenant tu en as
trahi pourtant ils veulent accéder il
faut des petites patates passait pas
avant mais s'excuse même après ce point
par an ouais pas mal
même mario c'est qu'ils savent être
entendu qu après une princesse il a pas
encore pécho à l'aller mais elle repart
se fait prendre par l'odeur sais pas ce
qui se passe non plus dans le château
avant là elle même est en recul
découvrez la cheffe de cialis si c'est
pas déjà fait vous pouvez également vous
abonner à la mienne bien sûr si c'est
pas fait non plus donc rendez vous
demain à 11 heures
ciao
[Musique]